hi there Steve Kaufman here I'm back in
Palm Springs for another few months
avoid the rain and Vancouver the last
video I did I'm trying to address these
problems that people identified in
different languages the first one was on
the subjunctive in French and today I'm
going to talk a bit about phrasal verbs
because that came up quite often from
learners of English and so obviously I'm
not as I said with the subjunctive I'm
not a teacher I'm also not a teacher of
English but I'm not even a learner of
English so I'm not entirely sure of the
nature of the difficulty that people
feel with phrasal verbs but I had a look
at phrasal verbs now the first thing
that strikes me is that most phrasal
verbs revolve around the very common
most common verbs in the language get
give calm go and so forth so and I've
often felt this that you know trying to
learn the most common words in the
language it's kind of difficult because
you know some people are interested in
the names of fruits and vegetables and
other people are interested in more
complicated missing fell down interest
education balancing the budget so it the
nouns depend more on your on your area
of interest but the verbs tend to be
more or less common so to try and learn
the most common verbs you can easily
google and find a hundred most common
verbs in English those you should really
know all right and anytime you see them
if you're working at link you want to
save those and really understand how
those verbs are used in English it's not
so much a matter of how they change as
in Romance languages or some other
languages it's more a matter of how
they're used and which words they are
used together with and that's why it's
so important for example at Lincoln I'm
going to refer to link because that's
how I learn languages but you can do the
idea is the same whether you're using
link or not when you see a verb in
English
and verb underline as much of the phrase
that that includes that verb as possible
now in link we have the opportunity to
say first of all if you save a word you
will save a chunk automatically the
system saves a chunk and when you look
at that word that you've saved say this
verb you'll see five or six or seven
examples of that verb being used and
you'll see which words it is used with
so the idea of phrasal verbs is that
certain I mean it's true not only for
verbs but certain verbs are used
together with certain other words
typically with prepositions sometimes
that changes the meaning or gives it
different meaning for example I know a
lot of non-native speakers of English
will often say I found out a book at the
library instead of I found a book at the
library okay and the word find out means
more to discover whereas to find is to
come across something come across
there's another phrasal verb come very
common verb you come by something you
come across something and you come at
something so that the preposition behind
the verb will sort of give a different
nuance and sometimes a completely
different meaning to the verb so you
have to learn that combination as a
different term almost but you have to
begin by being conscious of which words
are used together with other words and
in particular with with words so one of
the things that I have done for learning
other languages like Slavic languages is
is to tag the words that I save so if
you are learning English at link you
tagged every verb that you feel is
involved in phrasal verbs before we get
into that let me say that because a lot
of our members at link are saving
phrases it is very likely that if you
come across it's almost certain that if
you come across a verb that's used in a
longer phrase a common longer phrase
some
we'll have saved that as a phrase so you
can see the list of phrases that have
been saved by other users and you can
choose one of them and save it to your
database so you can actually save either
verbs that are commonly used in phrasal
verbs or the phrases to your database
then you can tag them you can tag them
as phrasal verbs so just for the fun of
it
I went and tagged a bunch of verbs that
are commonly used in phrasal verbs so
you have turn okay so if I look at turn
and I open that I see that the samples
turn in turn okay here's one in turn
which isn't quite a phrasal verb turn
those three things into turn something
into turn it into practical example turn
on the TV so those are here again or
turn about and travel so just by saving
the word turn I pick up automatically
six phrases using the word turn or if I
know I also chose no as a phrasal verb
in other words a verb that gets involved
in phrasal verbs you can also save you
know the past tense new but most of us
know that being know their limits I know
my okay know well so this one is less
useful let's take for example give give
it to them give it back give it away so
give us a clue so you know I could go on
and on here get which is a big one in
phrasal verbs and get to a modicum get
it in front of get encouraged get to
sleep get back so what I'm suggesting
here is in order to get better at
phrasal verbs you have to be exposed to
them so you have to pay attention when
you're reading and listening if you hear
a phrasal verb in other words a phrase
using a certain verb you have to get
used to the way that verb and certain
other words function together as a unit
so you have to pay attention so one way
of doing
you tagged a bunch of these say it link
and then you review them as a group
alright so the other thing is getting
back to find out I I if I were a
non-native speaker I would get to what I
can understand the phrasal verbs as much
as possible but I would avoid using them
because I'm there's a chance I'll get
them wrong so rather than saying find
out I would use discover and generally
speaking phrasal verbs are less formal
than what is often their Latin origin
equivalent and so in formal writing it's
in fact often better not to use the
phrasal verb so I would treat phrasal
verbs not as some great big exceptional
thing it's simply an example of the rule
that in any language we have there is a
tendency for certain words to be used
together with other words this is
sometimes referred to as collocations
which is again a difficult term we
needn't learn we just need to know that
certain words are used with other words
and that the more naturally you put
these words together the more the way
you put words together is typical of how
words are used the more native-like
you're gonna sound therefore you should
save words or you should excuse me
phrases you should focus on phrases when
you save a word you should pay attention
to which words are used with that word
and that will help you not only on
phrasal verbs per se but even such
things as you know listen to so many
times you hear the non-native speaker
say I listen him
whereas I listen to him okay you can
tell him but you can't listen him you
have to listen to him so that it's not
just phrasal verbs it's the idea of
which verbs take which prepositions
which verbs are used with other ver
other words and that's something that
should be a major part of your language
learning and again not only for English
but for any language focusing on which
words are used with which other words
and that will make you you know a more
natural speaker of the language because
you you can't you can't just get a book
of all the key phrasal verbs and read
through the book and hope that somehow
you'll remember them you have to develop
habits through your listening and
reading so that you naturally start to
use these words correctly so there I
hope that's useful and because I'm not a
learner of English I would like to know
if in fact that is useful and maybe some
people could tell me what specifically
they find difficult about phrasal verbs
alright thanks for listening bye for now
[Music]